hi everyone i'm emily and i'm tucker i'm
dominican and i'm half chinese and today
we are swapping foods we're going to try
each other's favorite foods from our
respective cultures ah
okay dominican pastalitos what's the
difference between a pastelito and an
empanada we just say pastelito
it's an empanada these are soup
dumplings rice roll and this is a shrimp
ball oh i can't do the shrimp one how
are you allergic to
shrimp there too oh no
it's okay we can oh god
if you don't see pastelitos in any
celebration they're doing it wrong i'm
gonna end in some sort of divorce yeah
yeah
take like a little bite suck the soup
out of it
kind of juicy two set and i'm kidding
i would eat like a hundred no if fans
are butts like i would eat a hundred i
would eat a hundred of these also is it
bad that i'm eating it with my fingers i
could literally eat a hundred of these
i'm not lying
it's so good i love this here's how i
eat it i go for the meat first and then
the edge some people love just like the
edge which i think it's crazy just to
want the edge so
no offense but it's kind of like someone
who eats pizza crust first yeah
it's not a normal thing to do and it's
kind of [ __ ] up that they do that will
come
that's fine good
good so we have now pork bunny um how do
you usually you just like pick it up i
think you can pick that one up and then
just bite it yeah
what is the cream
the cream this is good i'm happy that it
ended up being good
we are swapping soups
soup my mom likes to make this when
we're like really sick we also eat soup
and it's like scorching hot outside it's
like 90 degrees latino parents they're
like it's very hot outside i think i
should make some soup
my mom always says that if you eat hot
food when it's hot outside it makes
outside feel less hot which i don't
think is science i think that's just and
this is hot and sour soup and then this
is egg drop soup they like take eggs and
they beat it up beat it up they beat it
kick the [ __ ] out of the eggs it's very
gooey okay
it's very soft
trying it i'm like oh i'm gonna be zen
i'm gonna be chill like
okay that's fine with dominican soups
like their goal is to get you full i
thought it was gonna be like raw oh it
cooks in uh yeah yeah it cooks in like
the hot dog
okay you have this by itself with
nothing
you don't dip anything on it yeah
i like this one it's so good it's also
hot but it's not like spicy that i'm
like oh like you know yeah yeah i would
understand like eating this when i'm
sick or on a really hot day
i really like this like the gelatinous
but i i could understand that if people
don't like it i usually don't eat this
like i wouldn't eat that but so you
don't like this to clarify you don't
like this but you're like here no but
like how do i say this just the meat
like the small little thingy there i
would eat it not this big thing this is
mondongo dominican style tribe soup and
tripe is the stomach lining stomach yeah
i used to like it as a kid not anymore i
don't i don't know maybe i should get
into it um wait so you've given me two
things that you don't really like
but everybody else in the culture likes
okay sure so
i like the other one you did yeah you
see
no problem here you just don't like it
i'm just it's just i like it but it's
not my favorite okay yeah that's fine
yeah yeah just let you know this is
roast pork and then this one is maple
tofu and i love them
i'm messing it up that you eat with rice
yeah
mmm that's like a nice kick your
chopsticks are upside down also really
yeah why didn't you tell me that just
like you're telling me no i think i'm
just gonna use the spoon i don't want to
disrespect anyone um
mix this and this yeah it's like a sauce
it's just there's that awkward
eating moment of it it's like crunchy
but then soft and sweet mmm
it's just me eating like enjoying myself
this is very sweet this is very savory
mondoto mondongo
i'm nervous what if you don't like it
i'm sure i'll like it well i'm not sure
we'll see
that's really good like the fat of the
tripe like melted into the soup and like
that like is coating my mouth and it's
so nice it's really good i'm glad you
like it you say mondongo to anyone
especially like dominican men they're
like oh like we're gonna be good
[Laughter]
my mom whatever she would go to the
asian market she would give me that yeah
little snacks for her firstborn son
these are snacks for you
oh yeah this is a whole meal
10 out of 10.
yay all right these are the drinks we
say country glue but it's country club
and then this is moritz
which is orange juice and milk what's
that translate there
die dreaming
die dreaming die dreaming yeah
die dreaming this is sanzo it's a yuzu
flavor with ginger
wait why this is just like like lemonade
it's like a citrus oh it's not your
regular schmegler lemony yeah it's not
regular this is your favorite yeah
so good
oh yeah that's really good yeah so good
was it called nightmare drink no
which is dye dreaming oh not nightmare
just died yeah okay yeah
mmm it's good yeah it's great
i was nervous because it's like orange
juice and milk sometimes when i like
tell people they're like what it's a
creamsicle
cheers
the hot and sour soup is my top it
wasn't spicy it was just right number
two is the pork bun oh my gosh i i think
i'm actually gonna take that home with
me my first favorite would be that
chicken empanada chicken pasta
chicken pasta
the chicken pasalito is my favorite boom
pasta
i'm so happy that you liked it because i
got nervous a little bit that you
weren't gonna like it so
no i was nervous that you weren't gonna
like myself to be honest thank you so
much for sharing your food with me thank
you